je serai un spectateur désengager je
commenterai avec une très grande liberté
[Musique]
c'est un personnage intelligent brillant
affable tactile séduisant et j'avais été
surpris lors de notre premier entretien
du caractère un peu sombre de son regard
je crois que c'est un homme qui est très
brutal mais qui a une très grande
détermination il fait partie de ce club
des jacobins qu'on retrouve chez marine
le pen d'ailleurs chez gaultier chez
makro ou chez mélenchon ou tout procède
de l'état où il faut tout centralisé où
l'homme incarne l'état tout ça nous
vient de louis xiv
[Musique]
c'est un homme qui veut bien faire mais
qu'il est ouvert
il a abordé les problèmes les uns après
les autres a tenté de les régler mais
n'a pas donné le sens à l'action
or on ne peut pas agir sans donner le
sens quand on est président de la
république c'est un quinquennat
contrasté où le bilan vaut mieux que tu
le récit beaucoup de décisions ont été
dans le bon sens et je crois que dans le
temps on reconnaîtra ça
[Musique]
à partir du moment où il a été candidat
à l'élection présidentielle via une
primaire tout est parti en vrille si je
puis dire il n'a pas respecté ce qu'il
avait lui même écrit et signé
[Musique]
il a incarné un moment donné ce qui
était le candidat des socialistes sans
vouloir être le candidat des socialistes
d'où sa contradiction citer deux acteurs
de la fin du championnat de hollande
c'est à dire manuel valls et benoît
hamon se sont affrontés et ont fini par
quitter le ps il ya là une image qui est
quasiment shakespearienne